[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
keep clapping
happy friday everyone or as cat likes to
call it why am i in handcuffs
so something weird is going on this
vaxxed versus unvaxxed narrative as if
they're jousting in the park like a
low-rent version of medieval times like
it's something you could bet on with
your bookie is it real
i mean we're americans with families and
within families there are disagreements
from sports to politics to health to
even easier choices like should we put
mom in assisted living or on a blow-up
mattress in the garage
laughing at mom in the garage in your
family there might be someone who smokes
or worse doesn't smoke
or they might have voted for bernie
sanders
maybe they get coffee enemas because
gwyneth paltrow said so
a shout out to ducey
we all laugh at this but we're
respectful yet there's an us versus them
narrative being pushed by the white
house and the media and they sound
identical it's like when someone shows
up at a party dressed exactly like
another guest and everybody asks hey did
you two call each other it's exactly
what we should be asking gen saki and
don lemon
here's joe millions of americans are
still unvaccinated and because of that
their communities are at risk many of us
are frustrated with the nearly 80
million americans who are still not
vaccinated we have the tools to combat
coven 19
and a distinct minority of americans are
keeping us from turning the corner
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin this
from a guy who was wrong on everything
here's the media
begin to read out tonight with a message
to republicans okay we get it
covent is the precious and you love it
you love kovitz so much you want it to
spread into schools at the office in the
walmart all the cruise ships and at the
club most of the people i know are
vaccinated are irritated and and really
impatient at this point with those who
are refusing for whatever reason to do
this easy thing to save us from this
nightmare pandemic the people who are
not getting vaccines who are believing
the lies on the internet instead of
science it's time to start shaming them
what else or leave them behind
because they are keeping the majority of
americans behind ah he's stupid
but what a gin up conflict
these creeps are like america's gym
teacher forcing us to play shirts in
skins dodgeball when what we really want
to do is play spin the bottle
it makes you wonder about the other
conflicts you saw on tv for example was
there really a conflict between all
black people and police police or was it
largely a narrative created for eyeballs
and angst eyeballs and angst i think i
saw them open for nine inch nails
or how about rich versus poor what if
the poor don't hate the rich they just
want to be rich and the rich would be
thrilled to help because it's not a
zero-sum game but where are the ratings
in that you don't have breaking news
every time a plane lands safely but two
but put two passengers beating the
living out of each other on that plane
then come talk to me or how about gender
do men and women really hate each other
or are gender differences what make men
and women irresistible to each other at
least that's the case with my female
fans
those grannies can't get enough of this
[Applause]
call me grannies but if you subtract the
media's fakery could it be that we
actually all get along which is deadly
for the media cnn wants you to think
that blacks hate whites and whites hate
blacks you make that happen and everyone
gets new shoes but the moment a hate
crime turns out to be false it's
disappeared like someone who hit on al
capone's wife
and so the backs versus unvax conflict
is about as real as an argument over a
rolex on the real housewives of atlanta
the vax and the unvaxxed aren't the
hatfields and the mccoys unvaxxed girls
are not forbidden to marry vac's boys
romeo and juliet never argued about ivor
mektin
it's all a fiction the entire vaccine
story really and truly is about people
deciding when they want to get the
vaccine the media however wants it to be
a war
much like this
thanks grant this is david brooks from
the chess news network we're in new york
city where the vaccination debate is
tearing couples apart hopefully
here's a young couple now excuse me
excuse me uh sir uh were you just coming
from getting vaccinated uh well no i
just i wouldn't got some chips chips are
you saying the vaccine contains
microchips
honey who is this guy no are you
vaccinated well no i just had covid so i
have antibodies still so my doctor says
i don't really i don't need to get it
quite yet sir how do you feel about this
woman trying to murder you
wait are you putting our family at risk
by not being vaccinated i'm the mother
of your kids not anymore
i i had to drop out of law school to
stay home with them so you could pursue
your dreams honey the band is going to
make it
the vaccine debate tearing couples apart
back to you graeme
[Music]
i don't know what i like more cat's
shoes or the cameo from the fire engines
but i've said this before if americans
fight amongst themselves the people in
power escape our collective wrath about
their own corruption and incompetence
it's why corporations try to be woke
hoping the activists don't realize all
the bad stuff they do sure we make
underage labor work in horrendous
conditions but we're going to use two
trans actors and a mexican dwarf who's
legally blind in the first ad campaign
for these sneakers so that'll get these
whiners off our backs
since trump left the white house cnn no
longer has the conflict and no longer
the viewers there are no more trump
versus never trumpers and mysteriously
black lives matter just disappeared
but as their ratings collapse like
hunter biden on an exhausted hooker
they realized
they needed a new war the vaxxed and
unvaxed which distracts people from the
real problems that both dems and the
media worsened and that's crime
homelessness the collapse of our social
order food prices rising faster than pot
seeds in cat's apartment
observing their own complicity both cnn
and biden craved divisiveness the us
versus them would save them oh at first
they hated the vaccines under trump now
under biden they're positively fascist
about the jab trump vaccine bad biden
vaccine good joy reid please pick up the
white courtesy phone
i understand the hesitancy one listen i
was hesitant when donald trump was out
there controlling the cdc and
controlling the fda and manipulating
them and making them put out falsehoods
anybody rational was hesitant ah
now it was now it's irrational
unity is scary because it means the
media isn't necessary so they
choreograph their coverage exactly to
the democrats liking create dissent
among the ranks so those in power remain
so and their dissent must be directed at
the non-vaxxed an easy target until you
look at them closely and find out who
they are black suspicious of government
medical edicts women worried about
getting pregnant or currently pregnant
young fit people willing to risk getting
covered because they're so damn fit and
risk just about everything else
the immuno-compromised and other
medically unable to take the vaccine and
undecided people still make it up their
minds see how different they are you
might even use the media and the dems
favorite word diversity
but in this case diversity hurts their
argument so you won't hear that but we
get it joe and cnn are both in free fall
in joe's case literally
joe needs something to save himself from
afghanistan
cnn needs something to save them from
themselves and that's why they sound
exactly the same biden should start
every speech with this is cnn
because now they're both tainted they
have more contempt for a pregnant woman
weighing her vaccine options than the
mostly peaceful protesters who killed
cops and did 2 billion in damages last
summer the fact that cnn has even 300
viewers anymore is scarier than running
into wolf blitzer on a nude beach
and joe needs you
to blame your neighbor so you don't
blame him it's not his incompetence it's
their stupidity some unifier yoko ono
did a better job of bringing the beatles
together
demonizing the unvaxxed is joe's ways of
inoculating himself from culpability but
sorry joe you are a breakthrough case
the inoculation failed and so did you
america is going to stick together
whether you like it or not hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else